dans le temps parce que vous nous l'avez dédié
disco le soir je le met ici quand
il nous faut du temps pour nous endormir
minimum 3 1
c'était l'occasion de se défouler
un peu pour dire à Dieu quelque chose qui est
toujours un peu de ma voix
au lieu de cela, il ment à propos de la Madeleine où
la plupart du temps des trucs
faux vêtements oui non
[La musique]
une fois le château exploité nous commençons
Quartiers espagnols
d'autres familles grandissent dans tous les domaines
n'est-ce pas pour dire comme tu dis la Camorra
pensez-vous que la Camorra est une norme
crise comme je le sais
je ne veux pas comprendre
chaque titre quand la famille est là
parler ils se tirent dessus ruelle par ruelle
ils disent peut article à côté du système e
peut-être que si nous montons c'est la thèse
alors tournons dans la famille et faisons le mien
famille nous libérons
aux commissaires à cet égard
c'est-à-dire qu'à bord je peux vous dire ce qu'il y a
il sait tellement pourquoi nous décidons de tuer
seraient amusés car ils étaient plus
mort à naples de la guerre i
conseillers en guerre oui c'est ça
guerre quotidienne
[La musique]
les affaires de rome les affaires de
pari
l'affaire de la constitution qu'il y a
ce ne sont que des organisations criminelles
ils ont un seul but pour faire de l'argent aux entreprises
arsham comme tu dis en france ici en
Italie, nous avons le phénomène de
Camorra de la mafia mais on nous le doit
poser un problème
appelons-les belle baby gang est là
rajeunissement car il y en a un
répression constante par les
appareil judiciaire
[La musique]
en quelques années ils ont arrêté
des centaines et des centaines d'affiliés au
camorra
Napolitain capturé son nom était
en haut de la liste des plus recherchés
Camorra 44 personnes tenues pour responsables
d'association de type mafieux était le
deuxième sur la liste des 30 plus fugitifs
dangereux
entre dans la prison et il y a dehors
armée de remplacement et de réserve
crime organisé mais voulant
par les colonnes il y a des milliers de voyages
Arrive qu'il y a place nives la médecine
20 ans
nous descendons demande vers Juda
nous avons dit bien
ainsi sont ceux que nous avons perdus
parce que ce n'est pas vrai que ça peut être toi
couper le problème est que je suis
toujours haut sont-ils commencent à se mettre
tu me dis mais un garçon de 11 ans qui
il devrait jouer au foot
parce que ça nous fait j'ai vu l'amour que ça nous fait
lui une machinerie de mode
nous voulons
Naples
le pouvoir n'a pas été le premier à dire
pistolet parce que si je ne me bats pas, ils monteront
[La musique]
trois jours actuels reggio pendant qu'il l'a
fini
ils voyagent avec des fusils avec lesquels ils tirent
les enfants tirent sur les femmes
aujourd'hui nous avons ces jeunes vingt ans qui
ils ont la mort dans leur coeur
maintenant il y a le problème des gangs de bébés
les situations beaucoup
quatre personnes ont considéré les critiques
responsable à Bari et adolescents
faire le sens dans une arme à feu pour
beaucoup de choses, parfois même des menaces
arriver en code sur les réseaux sociaux
pour ma part la vie a dit
taille rajeunissement du goudron qui
malheureusement il pense que ça a changé mais il y a eu
jeunesse
[La musique]
selon les Espagnols ont volé bébé www2 pour
ce qui dure
et oui parce que le soleil est noir
c'est quelqu'un de nouveau travail en duo
Kalachnikov quelqu'un muzzi
[La musique]
l'homme
marquez particulièrement le vôtre
territoire dire que je suis un peu c'est-à-dire je
enfants dans ma maison pour venir à
commandement du lys, je monte à la maison et
Je ne te laisserai pas partir tout de suite
Je pense que c'est bien sous la maison de la sparte oui
organiser les cinq gars prendre le
nouveau l'histoire n'est pas une autre ai
estomacs symétriques scooters 23 i
les scooters font la propagation une fraction de
la seconde était de 5 minutes une chose mais
tout ce que je veux tirer et
réformez à partir de là où vous avez commencé
le message ici le me voici ici que
viens chez moi
Et si je te trouve dans la rue, le griffon n'est pas
nous aurons plus d'apprentissages en tête de table
[La musique]
9 balles de calibre 19
l'épisode correspond à
quarante-septième propagation depuis le début
de l'année à Naples
[La musique]
suit
quand à la place il y a quelqu'un qui
équipe expérimentée de loin pour le re
seulement la balle tu ne sais pas où elle peut
aller peut-être frapper un poteau de la
la lumière avec laquelle il y a une voiture la trouve
beaucoup de gens comprennent comment c'est arrivé
80 du dépassement
beaucoup de jeunes sont à moitié adolescents
ils veulent tout tout de suite
ils n'ont pas de codes, beaucoup d'entre eux en ont
ils arrosent tu prends les pilules oui
drogues avant de commettre un crime
[La musique]
lui-même signifie qu'ils tirent sauvagement et
ils forcent les gens à s'allonger
baisser puis augmenter en Campanie
malheureusement aussi ceci et ces jeunes
qui tirent dans les carrés alors que
avant que la pègre ne tue le tueur
juste cette personne va
maintenant et changer totalement la mentalité
qui tire sauvagement en frappant
même les innocents
ces dernières années, il y a eu 478
morts de victimes innocentes 470
[La musique]
il y avait une dame assise à la table avec le
bébé tout à coup un est venu j'ai
commencé à tirer sur le nôtre
la pression finit par frapper les deux
la grand-mère que l'enfant alors n'est pas
rien compris un instant c'est la porte
toujours paniqué et en mal 1 puis conduit
agitation
nous avons besoin d'une période de temps nous avons passé un bon moment
finalement conduire mais malheureusement à naples
aujourd'hui nous commençons à vivre une réalité
différent de ce qu'il était il y a de nombreuses années
[La musique]
nous sommes en danger les gens deviennent fous
ils font les attaques
donc pas du tout de rappels de données et
Je pense que oui parce que tirer sur des gens
il a été tenté par la fin
de nous, c'est-à-dire qu'il a répandu les coups de feu
tiré en l'air par ces petits garçons sur
les scooters sont à l'intérieur du
organisations criminelles et clans de buis
ils tiennent ces petits enfants et jettent un
double signal un signal disons
terrorisme à basse résolution
le tir générique et dire ici
nous sommes en charge
J'ai ici nous voulons nous conduire donc c'est
un avertissement aux autres clans mais c'est aussi un
avis à l'état ici nous commandons
avec la rangée de robots
alors les gars ce soir allons-y pour un
service qui est désormais solide car déjà avec
sortir plus ou moins
l'activité que nous devons aller faire e
c'est-à-dire que nous le faisons depuis un certain temps
celui du recensement et du suivi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait à
baby gang dans les différents quartiers du
ville on y va tous en groupe
donc nous n'avons pas à nous séparer d'accord
CA va bien
eh bien nous ne pouvons pas le faire
[La musique]
et votre état d'esprit avant de partir
en service mais certainement avant tout
les yeux toujours ouverts dans ma vision mais
Moi qui ouvre toujours les yeux toujours ouvert
neuvième
nous prenons la pièce un casting
on descend, il l'a sorti, on allume des dîners
envers Judas nous avons
bonne nina
non
je n'ai pas vu
Comment ça va
quand il ne peut toujours pas jouer au football
nous blessons
Oui
alors depuis prenons ce nom
Diego a documenté son passé
scooter ouvre ma selle
c'est un endroit correct
attribue généralement un groupe annonce a
connu le territoire
mais responsable
malaxé
ce sont les initiales du patron ici
propre planche sur les murs
Oui
la méthodologie par laquelle
les gars on vous dit
grandir dans ce contexte criminel e
donc
si oui s'ils veulent entreprendre cela
mec
évidemment ils doivent s'adapter au téléphone
exact de dire même la terre
où habitez-vous via le numéro comme il l'a fait
précisément cette activité de contrôle pour
vérifier si
nous sommes augmentés de l'inséré lorsque
supérieur
précisément en vue de cela
nous nous souvenons tous
travailler dur pour fréquenter
des projets qui attirent l'attention
et très important par rapport au fait
que chaque fois qu'un
fait criminel auquel nous réussissons
identifier quelques sujets que nous pouvons
identifier l'ensemble du groupe qui compose
et qui est coupable en somme
mais aller
je voudrais y aller les gars
disons que cette image a changé
certains d'entre eux sont éclaboussés sont
ils veulent émerger ils veulent émerger
disons s'en fiche
[La musique]
et exigent des choix que les serviteurs font
avec un pistolet et surfer
si quelque chose avec un tatouage dédié à
un criminel mort
cette chose que nous disons vous fait sentir
l'identité d'un quartier pour
une association aussi une association
Camorra
mais en fait les enquêteurs travaillent
beaucoup sur les soi-disant sources ouvertes
va sur facebook je te ferai un
exemple, il s'avère que le garçon de la
clan de ward trajan et ami sur
facebook avec fourche guy e
afin que les enquêteurs puissent comprendre
qu'il y a des alliances
paradoxalement c'est encore plus facile
relire la composition et la dynamique
qu'il y a parmi les groupes criminels
la structure a changé aujourd'hui cependant
même la technologie alors il peut sembler
étrange mais les médias sociaux ont signifié que
Il n'y en a plus
les schémas précédents mais qu'il y a à la place
une évolution des cotations pour laquelle
beaucoup de choses, parfois même des menaces
venir en code sur les réseaux sociaux à part
des mineurs
il y a sûrement toujours eu un
changement de génération pour que vous ne le fassiez pas
disons ne jamais interrompre cette chaîne
[La musique]
l'état
nous sommes aussi tiago
et je ne le regarde pas
je peux
[La musique]
notre essayé
nous ne pouvons pas y aller non non
il se souvient que le système est plus un
la région de secondigliano est difficile
aujourd'hui comme tu veux
[La musique]
la nouvelle génération de la Camorra ce
l'abaissement de l'âge de la Camorra est
essentiellement en raison du grand
activité qui a été faite auparavant
qui a effacé je l'appelle les adultes
des familles Camorra e
problématique et relation je l'ai fait
alors qu'avant il y avait beaucoup plus de codes
par des citations de personnes
parmi les adultes que les garçons de
15 16 ans vivant avec une perte de conscience e
avec
manque de perception réelle de
ce qu'ils font
donc en fait ils sont beaucoup plus
dangereux
pour eux
pas des prédécesseurs
[La musique]
si tu me demandes toujours d'autres sortent
je vis ça par exemple cinq ans
il y a ils se sont jetés mettre 15 16 17
beaucoup
si tu veux nous avons charlie's quand
nous avons pris un mazzini
les gars ont bien bougé avec le
patte 450t 16 ans que plus vu le
mouvement pas du téléthon paci pas connu
tirer sont les canulars et le spectacle en retard
car qui a la main
qu'est-ce que 12 ans ont trouvé le
circonstancielle puisque j'ai fait une radio
géré par nous dans notre quartier
les gars qui nous connaissent savent qui ils sont
pendant deux ans ils l'ont fait avant moi
vous connaissez
parce que jamais dit et prouvé
j'y ai vu un truc
il n'y aura jamais de gagnant à mon avis
il n'y aura pas un mauvais qui gagne le
personne qui dit oui nous sommes faits parce que
sera toujours ce qui vient
[La musique]